منذ الرابع من يناير الماضي لن تتوقف
توترات في اسرائيل ازمه سياسيه وقضائيه
اطاحت بحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو تدفق الاف
الاسرائيليين الى الشوارع وسط تل ابيب
للاعتراض على مشروع قانون التعديلات
القضائيه حيث وقعت اشتباكات بين عدد من
المحتجين وقوات الامن لكن مشاهدينا ما هو
هذا المشروع الذي اججج اسرائيل غضبا اولا
المشروع ينص على ادخال تغييرات جذريه على
النظام القضائي هذه التغييرات من شانها
الحد ومن سلطات المحكمه العليا وتمنح
النواب سلطه اكبر في تعيين القضاه الذي
يتطلب حاليا موافقه السياسيين والقضاه
اعضاء اللجنه المعنيه ومن ابرز التغييرات
التي يقترحها المشروع هو بندو الاستثناء
الذي يتيح للنواب البرلمان باغلبيه بسيطه
الغاء قرار صادر عن المحكمه العليا طبعا
السائد في اسرائيل التي ليس لديها دستور
ان من صلاحيات المحكمه العليا الغاء
قوانين يقرها الكنيسه اذا اعتبرت انها
تتعارض مع القوانين الاساسيه للبلاد وهكذا
فان اقرار بند الاستثناء هذا من شانه
السماح للبرلمان باعاده وضع قانون رفضه
القضاه موضع التطبيق